uh this story i love because it's really
a bunch of different stories it's a
story about the absurd lies of the 2020
uh election that are still being told by
many right-wing media networks it's also
a story about really the futility of the
types of corrections that we only ever
get so what am i talking about let me
explain it to you there's a right wing
network oan so the way i kind of place
them on a spectrum of wacky is you've
got fox news which is slightly crazier
than the republican party you've then
got newsmax which is crazier than fox
news and then you've got oan which is in
a category kind of not really of its own
but it's in a very extreme category
along with real america's voice and
those types of channels and for months
and really quite frankly at this point
it's almost years after the 2020
election
oan was parroting and repeating and
repeating all sorts of lies about the
2020 election hosting the most unhinged
guests to comment on the 2020 election
they have now
been uh forced to settle a defamation
suit and they issued a sort of
retraction on air but it was only 36
seconds long
and we're going to look at it the daily
beast reporting oan finally admits no
widespread voter fraud after settling
defamation suit georgia election workers
were dragged through the mud on oan by
right-wing conspiracy theorists like
rudy giuliani now the network is finally
acknowledging there was no fraud so
let's take a look at this clip we now
provide you with this updated report
from georgia officials take a listen
georgia officials have concluded that
there was no widespread voter fraud by
election workers who counted ballots at
the state farm arena but that's not what
you told us for a year and a half
november 2020 the results of this
investigation indicate that ruby freeman
and wandria shea moss did not engage in
ballot fraud or criminal misconduct
while working at state farm arena on
election night a legal matter with this
network and the two election workers has
been resolved to the mutual satisfaction
of the parties through a fair and
reasonable settlement so so there's been
a settlement understand that that's what
they saying and clearly this report is
part of that settlement
now will they go right back to
immediately spreading lies because as
often is the case
when you have such a big lie that you're
telling and the the big lie that they're
telling is
biden stole the whole thing it was
georgia michigan pennsylvania arizona
they did dumps in the middle of the
night all this different stuff
the issue here is just about the two
individuals named freeman and the other
person so they're kind of like
correcting one tiny little slice of the
story
and then they can just go right back to
fomenting all of the same lies and uh
the settlement should really be
you have to mention this ten times a day
for a year in prime time and this gets
to the issue of corrections and why i
make every effort on this show to be
accurate and then when i get something
wrong i will start the next show with it
i don't i do everything i can not to
bury the correction because nobody sees
the correction right 36 seconds 12 of
which sort of really relate to the
settlement
um after a year and a half of spreading
this stuff it's just not enough it's
kind of like punching someone in the
face for three weeks in a row
and then on the last day you quietly say
i'm sorry and then you walk away and
that we're supposed to believe that
they've been made whole and that's
essentially what this is the damage has
probably been done
irreversibly in the sense that i don't
know what the numbers now are it's
probably around
20 to 30 percent of america that
believes the 2020 election was stolen by
joe biden and actually won by donald
trump
this correction on oan isn't going to
trickle down to the cult members
the settlement it almost should be like
a permanent banner that scrolls the
screen and says
we lied about 2020 biden actually won
but even the settlement isn't related to
that it's only think about how narrow
the settlement is it's
the two individuals we named
weren't involved
in funny business
in georgia
in 2020
and uh really this is a network that is
extraordinarily dangerous and the good
news is they seem to kind of be dead in
the water i don't even know that
anybody's watching oan you might
remember famously a couple months ago at
t and a couple of other cable carriers
said they're going to be dropping oan
and uh trump went nuts and all these
people went nuts but the hope is
that oan ends up shutting down not
because some regulator forces them to
but because everybody stops watching
that's that that's my desire and we'll
see if that happens we'll have their
quote
correction
up on our instagram which you can find
at david pakman show we'll take a quick
break and be back right after this
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video